in some of my recent writings I've
argued that you know global trade does
seem to be driving down wages for
unskilled or semi-skilled workers and
countries like the United States and
Western Europe and I think this is an
important political issue you know
there's no question that inequality is
risen in the United States wages you
know for ordinary workers have been
fairly stagnant or have only risen a
small amount you know while incomes at
the high end of the salary scale have
gone up a lot and at the very top of the
income distribution you know incomes
have gone up spectacularly so I do think
that's a very important issue I would
argue that trying to address that by
restricting trade is not likely to
succeed you know it makes the whole
country poor it's a bad way to treat the
developing world you know the developing
world is benefiting a lot from this
regime you know so if you look at the
whole look around at the whole world you
know do you want to try to pursue a
solution in the United States that's
going to make the poor countries poor
that doesn't appeal to me I don't accept
the notion that restricting trade can be
any part of a progressive agenda I like
to think of myself as a pragmatic
progressive so I think when you worry
about wages for ordinary workers in the
US which I do worry about I think you
have to look at the tax system in the
United States I think you have to look
at public expenditure on education and
key services that actually reach
ordinary people so I think what Larry
Summers is arguing is that there are
fiscal measures and policy measures you
could take that would really make life
better for the working class I don't
think Larry Summers is arguing against
the free trade regime but I think he's
smart enough to realize that if you
don't do something for ordinary workers
in the United States you may lose the
political support for free trade and
that really is an important engine of
the whole global growth
you